ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States
thank you first let me say I was shocked
and appalled by the news of yesterday's
shooting today we must come together and
abandon hateful rhetoric on all sides
from the marauding Mexican rapists to
the New Jersey Muslims still celebrating
9/11 from the enemies of the American
people at the New York Times to the
haters and the losers at the Washington
Post from the tens on the 5:00 to the
threes on the view everyone unity is not
just a tremendously talented stripper at
scores unity is also a concept I've been
told I'm supposed to care about do you
have any words that could calm and
anxious nation yeah
Run For Your Lives we're under siege
there's an army of liberal zealots
operating under direct orders from
Shakespeare and Kathy Griffin sir do you
honestly believe that that's what they
said on Fox News so that's what I'm
going with
sir can you comment on reports that the
Special Counsel is investigating you for
obstruction of justice
I would never obstruct justice she's an
even more talented stripper than unity
and she's blind and we all know that we
all know justice is blind but Robert
Fuller is currently how do you clowns
have any questions about the real news
from yesterday like I don't know maybe
it was my birthday guys and that's why
tonight's theme is party we're going to
have a huge party in front of the entire
country as I always say party before
country and as the great Julius Caesar
says Pizza Pizza can you believe it
what's wrong